you can't ask the people of Scotland to
be dragged back to another device of
referendum that they don't want when
they're not able to see what the two
options are Nicola Sturgeon says she
wants to take Scotland back to the
division of another independence
referendum in the next 18 months but we
won't know what breaks it looks like and
we won't know what independence looks
like and we're also divided in officer
country we're not in the place we were
three years ago where there was
overwhelming you know public and
political consent for this we're divided
right now the majority of people in
Scotland don't want this and this is
Nicholas surgeon's obsession playing out
once again at the same time though it's
not a great look is it for the
Conservatives to be on the side of not
giving Scottish people to say in their
future it's a bit like as if the EU had
just blocked the UK from holding a
referendum up well this doesn't just
about the Conservatives you know the
Labour Party has said that people in
Scotland should be able to see what
they're voting for as well the Lib Dems
have said the same this is about a
general sense of fairness even taking
away that Nicola Sturgeon herself
promised the people of Scotland that
when they answered this very question
just three years ago that would last for
a whole generation this is about being
on the side of the people of Scotland
the majority of people of Scotland don't
want to go back to the divisions of
another referendum and I think the Prime
Minister is absolutely right to see not
know there is going to be some change in
second stances isn't now with the UK
leaving the EU you were a passionate
remainder you must admit this as well
it's gonna hit the public finances it
could mean years of austerity that
people in Scotland isn't it right that
they get a choice on whether that's
something they sign up to well like
thousands tens of thousands of people
across Scotland who voted remain to stay
part of the European Union I'm furious
that Nicola Sturgeon seems to think that
my remain Vil is a green light to
independence it's not and that's why
there's so many people in Scotland that
are so angry that she's worked
incredibly hard desperately hard on the
fact to leverage everything that she can
since June of last year to this point
this week to see that brexit is a means
to hold another independence referendum
to leverage breaks to make it happen and
I think she's made a real mistake -
because she's admitted the Scottish
Government has said said in the paper
that they gave to the UK government that
they accept that Scotland is leaving the
European Union is leaving the European
Union as part of the UK or if it were
independent what she's also saying is
that she's not even going to she
even confirmed that she wants to go back
in as a full member of the European
Union immediately so she's saying that
leaving the European Union which would
happen in either event is the reason for
holding a vote on independence but she's
not even saying that if Europe's the
reason she would go back in as a full
member but it could be argued though
that Scotland could quite benefit from
this sort of halfway house like Norway
well the problem is you've already got
the foreign minister of Iceland saying
that after membership this halfway house
that you're talking about that's not on
the cards either so you've got the
foreign minister of Spain saying that we
wouldn't get back into Europe
you've got the First Minister of
Scotland Nicola Sturgeon since you might
not even pursue that as her first course
of option as her immediate option and
you've got the head of which our other
option which is to join after you've got
the foreign minister of Iceland saying
that that's not on the cards either so
you've got this ridiculous I think
deceitful proposition from Nicola
Sturgeon where she's saying to the
people of Scotland
we must drag you back to a place that
you don't want to go to answer a
question that you've already answered
and I just didn't like that answer
on the grounds of leaving Europe which
we're going to do anyway and we might
not even go back in it's clear you're
very comfortable attacking Nicola
Sturgeon you want to you angered you I
can tell but do you think that Teresa
may also needs to take some
responsibility for this as well she's
ruled out the idea of the single market
straight away doesn't she take some
responsibility too for being in a
situation where Nicola Sturgeon is able
to call for this referendum you
suggested that I'm angry I'm absolutely
calm this is a conversation that we've
had in Scotland for many years I wish
that we weren't still having it in
Scotland but the First Minister of
Scotland Nicola Sturgeon has tried to
drag us back there by putting this
proposition on the table on Monday I
will always defend the decision the
Democratic decision the people of
Scotland made to stay part of our United
Kingdom and I was advocate membership of
our union because I believe in a head
heart body and soul in terms of what's
on the table at the moment Scotland is
leaving the European Union it will leave
us part of the UK even Nicola Sturgeon
has admitted that even if there where
independence referendum on her time
frame Scotland would still be leaving
what she hasn't confirmed is whether we
would call back in or not what Teresa
Maher said is that she wants to have the
greatest amount of free trade
squats businesses and UK businesses
within the single markets the ability to
trade with and operate in was her exact
phrase it was in her Lancaster Oh speech
so one of the twelve kiosks of the UK
government in these brexit mobile CA
chutes and I support that
I want the freest Street with the
European Union and with other partners
around the world for our businesses here
in Scotland and across the UK it's
cherries made treating Scotland a bit
more like a subject than a partner in
all this thing because she hasn't been
keeping Nicola Sturgeon in the loop a
shoe she hasn't taken her considerations
about the single market in Baldor told
her in advance about what she was
planning to do she didn't give her any
prior warning about when article 50 is
likely to be triggered so she's
effectively making all these decisions a
hundreds of miles away from Scotland
without whisper of warning okay there's
about 60 different things in there let
Sun pick them one by one you say that
Nicola Sturgeon has complained that she
hasn't been given prior warning of
article 50 being moved it's not being
moved yet you say that the mayor's not
gonna give any excuse me ask me a
question with lots of different things
in it so let me address the points one
by one are you seeing that to reason me
he hasn't addressed the issues that the
Scottish government brought up within
their own paper that they pooped at the
UK government and yet several of these
issues were embedded in the Lancaster
House speech in the 12 points that UK
government put forward so for example
the Scottish government Nicola Sturgeon
specifically asked for workers rights in
the UK to be protected that was one of
the 12 key points the Prime Minister put
forward Nicola Sturgeon specifically
asked for a close cooperation on
training security matters and
intelligence matters that was one of the
12 key points put forward by Teresa me
Nicola Sturgeon specifically asked their
would-be assurances for EU rights that
was an issue that was you know is part
of the 12 key points put forward by
Teresa me so to say you know the SMP
might like to talk about being lured
because it suits their agenda and but
that's not to reflect the key
considerations that have been adopted by
the UK government so you don't think
Tory's the most done anything wrong then
it's all the blame is on Nicola Sturgeon
machine you should just nothing to worry
about she's played the whole thing
perfectly Oh Teresa me is wanting to get
the best deal for the whole UK including
Scotland as we leave the EU now I don't
know I don't doubt for a second that
it's going to be some tough negotiations
ahead but there's only one person that
wants these negotiations to feel and
that wants them and want to
use even the idea of these negotiations
for an ulterior purpose and motive and
that's to break up the United Kingdom
and that is Nicola Sturgeon so in terms
of who's playing with a straight bat in
this I know whose side I'm on now you've
got some pretty impressive approval
ratings if you look at recent poll for
example of Scottish voters your approval
ratings are better than Nicola Sturgeon
Kezia Dugdale Jeremy Corbyn and Theresa
May are you the person who can save the
Union look this is about what the people
have swapped them on and the majority of
people of Scotland not only did they
vote overwhelmingly two million will be
a good campaign note as well that does
come into it - I enjoy a good campaign
but I don't want dragged back to a
campaign that divides our country when
we were promised if we you know if all
the voters of Scotland if they paid
attention if they took it seriously if
they asked the questions if they got the
information of the voters that that and
that that decision would be respected
that's what they were promised in 2014
and people in Scotland they came out in
record numbers 85 percent the highest
proportion of people that have ever
voted onto a universal suffrage for
anything in the United Kingdom in less
than three years later and Nicola
Sturgeon says I didn't like your answer
I'm gonna drag you back there again I
will campaign if I have to but what I'm
saying is we shouldn't have to go back
there when people don't know what
they're being asked and when the people
of Scotland don't want it you clearly
don't want to have a and have a
referendum campaign but if there is one
it does feel inevitable or even though
the time you of course there is under
question would you step up and lead it
well Luke there's gonna be plenty of
people that lead right across the
country I'm sure I will be one of them I
will not be sitting holding the jackets
at the back I'll be making sure that I'm
putting my point stay in the front but
this isn't just about politicians this
is about the people of Scotland our
whole country voted in 2014 and we spoke
pretty loudly and pretty clearly that we
wanted to remain part of the United
Kingdom a Nicholas sturgeon unilaterally
can't take that away from us so would
you share a platform with labour then as
part of this campaign I've always been
able to share platforms with people
right across this debate and others
where there is common cause and I would
absolutely do so again and how about the
messaging if it was project for a long
time is it going to be a project
Armageddon this time what's the look
you're at laughs you're asking me to go
down several routes of hypotheticals and
I'm not prepared to do so this week the
First Minister of Scotland against the
will of the majority of people of this
country unilaterally decided that she
wanted to drag us back to a place where
she promised us we wouldn't have to go
she put a specific set of proposals on
the table to the UK government I think
the Prime Minister was absolutely right
to say that this can't happen within 80
months on the principle that the people
of Scotland need to know what they're
being asked to vote on and there needs
to be popular and public and political
consent for this that doesn't exist